l'artère pourrait être celle d'une ville
sinistrée l'intersection saint laurent
sainte catherine en arrachent le coeur
de montréal la rue fondatrice de
montréal m'ont laissé aller c'était le
coeur de montréal qu'on veut réanimé
grâce à un important projet immobilier
la pièce maîtresse est ce bâtiment de 15
étages rue saint-laurent au sud de
sainte catherine pour un coût total de
160 millions de dollars
une quinzaine d'états 15 étages pas une
quinzaine ses quinze étages un édifice
bâti en retrait de la rue ce qui
permettra de préserver les façades
patrimoniale de la maine
les gens qui vont se promener
subventionnera ce qu'ils vont voir si
ces façades réhabilité avec des
commerces au rez-de-chaussée alors avec
le regard de mauriac pour le rocket à
côté vous voyez la façade on va lui
redonner son lustre il ya pas de fenêtre
en haut
ce projet de 160 millions est rendue
possible parce que selon nos
informations l'occupant de l'édifice
sera hydro québec
ça permettra de regrouper ses employés
éparpillés et de financer indirectement
la relance de ce quartier à vocation
culturelle à l'arrière de l'édifice on
aménagerait une rue piétonne rue clark
de l'autre côté de la rue au 2 2 2
sainte catherine est
on construira ce spectaculaire édifice
en verre de sept étages
le défi est anti l'intersection reste
peu invitante gros problèmes au coeur du
quartier des spectacles qui veut
redevenir le secteur branché de la
métropole rang 10 ans imagine que les
gens qui vont venir à la sat au club
soda au métropolis ou au tnm vont avoir
du plaisir à venir déambuler sur saint
laurent
le projet sera présenté au public à la
mi avril et les promoteurs souhaitent
que les nouveaux bâtiments de la main
soit tous complétés d'ici la fin 2012
david genting radio canada montréal